warum bin ich nochmal nach hier unten
gesprungen ja meine damen und herren er
ist zurück der meister von minecraft der
beste spieler aller zeiten ist zurück
meine damen oder in einer riesigen
applaus wird kommt soll das freunde ich
befinde mich hier mal wieder ein
mannschaft ich habe das ganze schon sehr
sehr lange nicht mehr hochgeladen
das sehen wir auch daran dass da oben
steht finde einen baum schlage ihn für
holz
danke dafür ich habe monatelang an
minecraft mehr hochgeladen weil ich mal
wieder probleme mit meinem account hatte
ich hab das passwort mal wieder
vergessen weil ich bin ein dummer spaß
aber es haben sich sehr viele leute
wieder mal gewünscht deswegen hab ich
gedacht da zwar wieder hoch wollt ihr
übrigens dass ich mal mit max und sättel
minecraft projekt mache also ohne einen
scheiß mopac und ohne alles aber einfach
nur wir und diesen summen minecraft last
man leichter und bei 50.000 das ist eine
hohe zahl aber dann machen wir das 11
wir haben natürlich wie immer einen plan
am start und zwar lautet der wie viele
fucking spielmodi gibt es denn hier das
auch wieder hart komme es gibt irgendwie
so 20.000 verschiedene spielmodi für das
entscheide ich mich ist sowie games ich
bin ein richtiges night skate ich habe
schon die erste kiste gefunden meine
damen und herren und zwar befindet sich
dort drin
wir sind noch in der lobby ach du
heilige scheiße freundlich wurde erkannt
und zwar glp bist du das sofa wie soll
ich das jetzt zu überleben wir befinden
uns jetzt hier auf der karte wo sieht
das ganze hier aus die map kenne ich
persönlich jetzt nicht ich weiß nicht ob
ich in die mitte rennen soll ich glaube
eher nicht weil ich bin schlecht und
scheiße in der tat ich glaube jetzt nach
hinten habe hier natürlich direkt ne
kiste leder brust hanisch ist am start
das ist eine tolle lederjacke von
supreme die ich mir geholt habe ich
starte ein bisschen weil ich bin echt
nervös hinter mir ist gerade niemand das
ist sehr geil hier vorne ist eine kiste
da haben wir mal wieder kein schwert
drin das ist im ultra gut falls ihr euch
übrigens fragte was ist überhaupt so
weit wie games was ist überhaupt ein
krad minecraft sowie games das was ich
spiele hier bitteschön für die erklärung
jetzt geht darum dass viele verschiedene
spieler hier auf einer map zusammen sind
und kisten suchen müssen denn in diesen
kisten befinden sich waffen und mit
diesen waffen kann man andere spieler
töten und jeder gegen jeden
und ich bin hier war hier noch nie gut
drin tnt und eine lederkappe das ist ja
neues freuen da haben wir vielleicht mal
ein schwert für den lieben conny acht
davon dass noch eine kiste kommen meine
damen und herren als mal rein was
befindet sich darin ein schwert wohl
freut mich oh mein gott da hinten ist
ein spieler jetzt gerade ist dies bei
und der klettert jetzt nach vorne glaube
ich in den zug rein das heißt das ist
meine chance eventuell ganz kurz mal
eben hier in die kiste und zuschauer die
schon geleert cool freut mich hier haben
wir auch noch ne kiste dann schaue ich
mir die auch noch mal eben rein wir
haben endlich mal einen stein axt drin
soll damit können uns ja schon mal so
ein bisschen während zumindest gegen die
anderen weiß ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht
wo ich hin laufen soll
weil ich die map einerseits nicht kenne
und andererseits auch ein bisschen angst
habe dass andere spieler eventuell
besser kann als ich hier haben wir noch
eine kiste wir schauen mal was sich
darin befindet endlich mal ein paar
schwerter das heißt wir können uns das
schwert gegen die steinhauser ist das
gold wert besser als ein stein ext4
angriff schaden neuen angriff ich
behalte lieber die stein axt was haben
wir denn hier vorne hier vorne haben wir
das ist das ist eine schlucht ich
probier mal hier runter zu springen ohne
dass ich irgendwie schaden nähme genauso
als bin ich hier unten drin der im
geisaer gibt dem skills
warum bin ich nochmal nach hier unten
gesprungen ja geil luca hast du wieder
super gemacht
da sitze ich hier unten drin sondern der
ist das wirklich dick ist oder ist das
der fall ich bin mir echt nicht sicher
also ich klicke jetzt einfach mal drauf
und wir sehen ok rose wurde das ist ein
geräusch ich glaube das war ganz einfach
nur das öffnen der kiste war die erst
mal das rindfleisch reihen genauso muss
dass da vorne werde ich jetzt
was ist das hallo freunde ist hier
vielleicht irgendwann doch einmal gang
gehe ich mal gehen kann genauigkeit da
erstmal hier eben an der seite die hand
hoch genau jetzt darf ich mal hier vorne
durch wär echt mal gut zu wissen ob sich
hier hinten vielleicht doch irgendwie
kiste befindet vielleicht irgend einen
geheimgang was
wo bin ich denn hier gelandet hier vorne
ist ein weg nach oben
was ich hier befähigt ist noch mal weg
nach oben genau dann kann ich hier rum
laufen dann bin ich hier hier sehen wir
dass ich hier nichts befindet wenn ich
hier wieder nach unten hier sehen wir
unglaubliche hitze besser kiste oh mein
gott ok war und fische und rohes
schweinefleisch das ist genau das was
ich in diesem moment jetzt hier
gebraucht hat meine damen und herren
also wir gehen mal hier hoch klicken
dass das match steht bloß gedacht sie
vertont
da kam dann irgendein typ an und wollte
adela ja der dann wahrscheinlich alle
reiseleistungen kollege könnt ihr beiden
könnt ihr wohl nicht aber wann war ein
gutes match freunde ich wurde dritter
das fühlt sich für mich an wie der erste
platz das war's jetzt jedoch von mir
meine damen und herren ist ein bisschen
kürzer geworden ich habe allerdings auch
nicht viel zeit weil ich gleich nach
hause fahren muss weil ich die tage
weisheitszähne raus bekommen das heißt
die tage kommen wieder auf einem kanal
in dem ich solche attacken habe das wird
überhaupt nicht cool eigentlich wenn ihr
allerdings wollt dass ich mit max und
seppel ein minecraft multiple projekt
starte indem wir einfach total
bescheuert minecraft spielen herr lass
mal leichter und jetzt meine damen und
herren kommen wir ja ich finde ja immer
so eine epische musik an aber es ist
letztendlich irgendwie eigentlich nur
das auto
hier können jetzt hier in einen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
schenken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]